[Music]  this is camaria a milky eagle owl  the largest african owl it is found  throughout sub-saharan africa the eagle  in their name refers to their large size  females are much larger than males  sometimes over a third bigger  they feed on a large variety of animals  everything from mammals fish rodents and  even large birds  they hunt from a perch using their sharp  vision to spot prey before flying in and  seizing them with their powerful talons  while it is a dominant bird its  population has seen a decline due to a  combination of loss of suitable habitat  hunting disease and drought  their slow reproductive rate has made it  difficult for the population to recover  quickly  this is the milky eagle owl  you